[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to LED live
today we're gonna be talking about the
new show
owl house our cartoons today just
getting blatant find out on this episode
of LED live you wish we'd like to thank
our patreon supporters without you guys
we couldn't have this show thanks to you
we can put out free content and also if
you'd like to check out more content by
us that's on DVD only we have it on our
store you can also buy Vimeo digital
download copies you don't have to use
DVD but we got a lot of cool
documentaries that are not on YouTube
full of great stuff also if you like
t-shirts we got some cool t-shirts this
isn't one own kindy is wearing one
Scotty's got a new one check out our
shop that helps support our ministry and
you can really wear your witness and
just look cool doing it
alright so Disney has a new show coming
out have you guys heard about our house
yes a little bit of it a lot of people
have sent us links on this show yeah
about articles and different things
yeah actually Newsweek had a really
in-depth article about it they
interviewed the creator of the show and
really all you got to do is read that
article and know like this is not a show
for any Christian especially no kids man
like this is just it's getting darker
and bolder you know cartoons when we
were growing up were kind of hidden like
it was like oh it's Pony magic you know
Captain Planet they got their rings they
were taking care of the environment
heart wind water you know
[Music]
that's all elemental occultism but it
was always wrapped up in this like oh
it's really about taking care of the
planet how it's just like hey we're
witches and we summon demons and I'll
show you let's just watch this trailer
so this one day I found a portal and
ended up someplace I could have never
imagined okay well I totally have
imagined it but even better this is the
boiling Isles amazing kind of place you
just want to wake up every day friendly
neighbors cutie pie someday I'm going to
be just like her want to see more of the
Isles just a short staff right way is
the town of Bones perhaps there's
anything better than people watching in
the demon realm the marketplace has the
best stuff in town that has four hooves
and wants to buy a potion my eyes are
down here there's the library and hack
site the most amazing magic school ever
I even got a push back the aisles I know
sometimes it can seem a little different
it's very stinky and gross but if you
look at it from a different perspective
it looks just like home Yoho
alright so are we reaching for anything
they use blatant language right pretty
blatant like you can't get any more
clear yeah if you pull out a checklist
everyone is checked for wizardry magic
demons subtle little jokes on not even
subtle yeah jokes yeah like back in the
day it was kind of like oh I'm a wizard
or sorcerer and it's kind of you know
people could say oh that doesn't really
mean anything but this is like we're
witches in the demon realm right there
was a button about it and just
glorifying it like I she said I want to
be hopefully someday I'll be more like
this witch and you know this place you
want to wake up every day right right
oh yeah the boiling I mean instead of
like get burning in fire or it's hell I
mean they're just like a little bit of a
change but boils
yeah tell oh yeah yeah you'll find out
the the artist or the creator of this
thing she is completely open about it
so that this is the Newsweek article
that our house creator's talk bringing
creepy back to Disney with a dash of
boshy you don't have Bosch cos he is an
artist from like the medieval time
periods and he just drew these
terrifying pictures of his vision of
Hell like I mean people in boiling
cauldrons and people sliding down saw
blades and it's just completely
disturbing so to continue she said from
a Huronia must Bosh that's the guy I'm
just talking about it's a Mickey Mouse
spending eight years growing up in
Catholic school tears developed an
affinity for classic religious painters
like John Barr and huronian muss Bosch
whose twisted takes on angels and demons
would make for a cool show in that art
style is what she said I was exercising
some demons by working from them Wow
Tara said when Dana who's the creator of
the show when Dana first approached me
she said that we're trying to make this
demon realm a part of Disney which is
something I didn't think would happen
caneta said we really wanted to make
this demon realm feel like home and just
had to figure out a way to how to do it
so how to whitewash it how to make it
acceptable yeah how to make it palatable
family show you guys remember the movie
the compass I remember when it came out
so it did terrible at the box-office
thank goodness it was a terrible movie
but that one they had little demons that
were in animal shapes and I remember
seeing some interviews with some of the
kids and they were like you know it'd be
terrible not to have this little demon
friend follow you around everybody has
this animal demon which represents that
in a person who they are I think having
a demons like instead of wearing you
know wearing your heart on your sleeve
it's your heart walking
side by side by you and the most
terrifying thing would be to see a human
being without their demon this is just
like what like this isn't disturbing to
anybody but yeah I guess this is where
we're at in her society Rand but he's a
demon yeah that's just kinda like as
long as I make it look cute we can
accept anything you know what actually
Seth MacFarlane the creator of Family
Guy made a movie called Ted and he we
got to find the quote but he said
something about as long as a cute teddy
bear was saying it he could get away
with like saying wow I mean like so it's
a terrible movie things that wouldn't
even be allowed in a movie that God
allowed because it was a little crazy so
this is the the artist box or whatever
she was highly inspired by this artwork
and as you can see you know it's flames
everywhere just like here's her world
and you can see it here's a mountain
down at the bottom of a mouth and horns
and then look at this tower it's
identical it's this tower with these
thorns coming out of it and this
circular thing on top
so I was very clear that she was highly
inspired by this and she's not shy about
I mean she openly says it well we were
add as a society no longer does the
devil have to clothe himself as an angel
of light he could just show himself as
he is as the demon and people are
flopping around like oh cool look at
this guy that's why we have shows like
Lucifer yeah so here's you know they get
to see the whole world you see the smoke
coming up and it's just it's hell I mean
you know it's interesting that they're
making like hell which is has been
feared for centuries people have had
this like kind of picture of it being
this terrible place and now it's like
they're literally flipping this upside
down on its head and making this like a
desirable place you know if you think
about it people have in general a very
twisted view of God and if you twist
that view of God in in society or that
view is twisted in your own mind then
you're really down to what are your
options if God is this evil horrible
person to you that you
can't figure out and don't think loves
you then on the other side you have the
devil dangling the golden cairns land
well you might as well enjoy the
pleasures of sin for a season right and
I think that's what people are buying
into it's not it I think if they
realized that there was hope if they
realized there was something better they
realize who God truly was and what he
wanted for their lives I don't think
they would turn to something like this
it wouldn't be appealing at all but you
know if you don't think God loves you
and you think he's this horrible monster
well that's interesting
correct me if I'm wrong people usually
come to that conclusion based off of
some really tragic experiences in their
life but they're like you know why
wasn't God there for me and they go down
that path this shows for children it is
like how long have they been on this
earth to have such experiences and that
some children do but this is more of
like teaching that God is bad more than
them going through so yeah yeah yeah and
if you a I guess if you have you've
never had an experience I would I would
wonder like where the parents and what's
their experience because even from an
early age you pick up on certain things
but especially little little kids you
know
well the creator of the show is raised
in a Catholic school and this is what
she's putting out now has she said
anything about her religious views no
besides communicating with demons and
exercising themes so here's another
portrait that he did you can see like
there's people in cauldrons and things
like that
here's another cool picture that he did
this is a scene from the show
I mean Wow boiling rate of demons
boiling people just like his art and
this is family entertainment this is
kids but it's just like oh man oh yeah
we want this place to be feel like home
yeah and then kids are like I can't
sleep you know I deal with that in my
house and my kids have not been exposed
to this I can't imagine what kids
nowadays you know are running around
with this kind of darkness in their mind
it's terrible yeah well the sad part is
you know if a parent showed him this and
the kid got scared they'd be like no no
it's fine
right and we'll encourage them to be
desensitized if your kid watches this
and is not disturbed by it I think
there's a problem yeah you don't mean
like there's there's a sensitivity there
that's numbed away it's gone and you
know cuz cuz even me as an adult I mean
this is like whoa I don't even know if I
want to look at this kind of stuff but
they're doing such a good job of
sugarcoating and making it real colorful
or cute you know the king of demons aw
you're so cute a little dog yeah I mean
this is more that guys are you can see
we've got these weird amalgamations and
I don't know what's going on here
a bird man eating a guy so this is a
real faint like piece of art from from
this time we go and find this in the
Vatican or something probably but here's
some of the characters from the show you
know same type of deal these weird
amalgamations multiple eyes mixture of
animal and man such as this you know
he's part animal part man is just really
not stopped though that was this scene I
was like wow it's a totally adult joke
just happened there you're paying
attention yeah which you know when their
parents over so a parent might say I
don't really like you watching that show
but then if they said that haha now I
got a chuckle out of it now yeah let's
watch that show together you know it's
kind of funny I'm just gonna say if the
parent is sitting there watching it and
they find something like that and they
do start laughing then that says
something to the child you know oh they
think it's funny oh it must be okay
exactly there's no problem here and I
would ask that parent would they sit
down with their child and watch a show
instructing how to take drugs you know
why why the concern for their physical
well-being and not the spiritual yeah
they say oh that's just a cartoon you
know oh good point so she continues she
wanted to pick my brain in the early
days of the series when the original
pitch was girl hangs out it with which
in hell that was her pitch I feel like
our house is bringing back a world where
you can laugh but also be grossed out
and maybe
scared dude her pitch was girl hangs out
with which in hell she's not hiding
anything it's not like oh it's a cool
mystical place and it's just a weird
wacky world no it's hell what's really
concerning okay so she wants a world
where you can laugh also be grossed out
and a little bit scared but this is a
children's show why are you trying to
gross out and scare little children
right right what's the purpose that's
the reason behind a monster why not have
a place that teaches your children good
moral values or something positively you
know enlightening what like why isn't
that a theme of a lot of these why is it
have to always kind of like gravitate
towards this type of content you know oh
yeah and in the first episode which
we'll go through some of that it's you
know always the same template there's
it's like there's no nothing original
about this and it just keeps coming out
like you're saying yeah how come we
don't have a show that focuses on
something good
what's even mine more mind-boggling is
that then society is up in arms and just
confused as to why these children going
through that become unfortunately messed
up adults yeah you know I'm going on
precise right so it goes on the
character designers were given the green
light to create what they felt would
work it's a demon world so we can do
whatever we want Tara said the lure of
the show is 70% made up by the writers
and artists Tara said with names of
demons and witches thrown in to add
depth the writers room for the show is
full of books on witchcraft witches and
spells to take inspiration from this
isn't made of fairy tales we're looking
at witchcraft books to get our
inspiration the owl house stars lose a
bright-eyed teenage human girl who
wanders into a portal that leads her to
boiling Isles in a world full of ghouls
monsters and demons lose finds comfort
and aid with EDA the owl lady a powerful
sorceress who has her own fascination
with human trinkets and doodads
together with King a pipsqueak demon
with a desire for chaos lose spends her
time learning the basics of witchcraft
witchcraft the main antagonist of the
pilot is the warden a monster wearing a
plague doctor mask voiced by Roger Craig
Smith the owl lady was the first
character tear Terris developed for the
show she's based around the woman who
raised me or the women who raised me my
aunt's my Nana and my mom they're all
the owl lady
Terris mused next came King a trickster
god turned tiny warrior which terrorists
relates the most to because he's just a
little guy that wants to be big she's
coming from it she's coming she's
approaching this show based off of her
own life experiences one thing I can
definitely I suppose be happy about is
she's being honest she's telling it as
it is she's letting you know what you're
getting yourself into
it's it's really good for us to do it
just the the minimal amount of research
can expose so much and then you can make
your decision as to what you want to
watch someone who was into devil worship
or any other religion other than
Christianity I suppose this will fall
right into you know what they like and
what they would support but for the
Christian yeah
I would really question you know your
loyalties if you submerge yourself in
something like this because there it is
it's this is exactly what it is like
here is your choice there's a lot of
conspiracy theories right right here on
this exactly I mean her growing up being
aware that there is a God a Satan you
know what I mean I mean no doubt if
she's had some sort of upbringing and
the understanding of this whatsoever I
mean it's a little alarming to me that
that she would flip it and promote this
kind of a thing I mean honor a diverse
for you Matthew 18 verses six whosoever
shall offend one of these little ones
which believes in me it would be better
for him to have a millstone that were
hanged about his neck and that he were
drowned in the depth of the sea like
that and that and that's red letter
Bible that's Jesus's words right there
so
you know I mean he's literally saying
like look if you're gonna make something
that's gonna take a little child and and
lead them astray I mean literally it
would be better for you if you were just
dumped in the bottom of the sea yeah and
and Jesus is a very patient forgiving
person to say that so yeah I'll add to
that second Timothy three but know this
that in the last days perilous times
will come for men will be lovers of
themselves lovers of money boasters
proud blasphemers disobedient to parents
unthankful here's a word I want to hone
in on unholy mm-hmm unloving unforgiving
slanderous without self-control brutal
and despisers of good as traitors
headstrong haughty lovers of pleasure
rather than lovers of God and I just did
a real quick search I think this is
fascinating that this is the first Cain
thing that came up I just typed in
Disney and witches on Google I just
wanted to see what would pop up first
article comes from cbn news it's an X
which warning about Disney's new Disney
show it's not a joke that realm is very
real and guess what show she's talking
about this one the alehouse interesting
yeah she said a new Disney cartoon is
teaching kids that being which is a good
thing it's called the outhouse and
recently premiered on the Disney Channel
the show tries to portray witchcraft is
a positive tool to fight evil some
people say there's nothing to worry
about when it comes to a children's show
like this arguing it's just make-believe
but one former witch and lesbian told
CBN s the prayer link that parents need
to be very careful about what their
children watch so that I actually
watched a movie that was very popular
when I was in high school and it was
called can you get raft a crab did you
see that no god I said well yeah I think
years ago that was the the girls that
were all into this and she goes on to
say and the movie was about for high
school which is that hell this power and
had all of this control she grew up this
lady in a dysfunctional home battled
depression and she saw the power in the
movie as a way out
I remember hearing these voices just
kill yourself just go away it would be
better off
if you would just die and so I started
to cut my wrists severely I remembered
having 56 cuts all the way up and done
my arms my arms were shredded and it
wasn't way in my mind that I was able to
escape and she goes on and talks about
there was this demonic hold on her life
and then she started it opened doors to
study witchcraft do spells incantations
study Wicca and well do you remember the
New Age couple that we had on our show
here and remember how he got into the
New Age Star Wars and Lord of the Rings
right that's right movies books right
you go to Barnes & Noble you look at the
Harry Potter section right there's a
massive Harry Potter section what's
right next to the Harry Potter sections
a lot of times those books are actually
right next side-by-side with pure
witchcraft books the real ones not just
ones that are like oh this is just a
make-believe story this is really how it
is and and when these kids go to these
sections over and over and over again
you read through all the material then
you're looking for more what are you
gonna grab a table to mark you're gonna
go to the next the next low in the Harry
Potter series they even used real
terminology and things I mean it was
based on real places real terminology
all that so even in that is you know
heavy dose of reality yeah this guy's
doing a story and the devil was just
looking for anyway and whether it's a
book or a movie once you just open that
door just a little bit slide right there
they mentioned that they had you know
their workroom was a full of witchcraft
books and stuff this was like a real
short scene it shows this pile of junk
and then it pans up real quick and I
paused it to see what these books were
this one's necronomicon necronomicon -
and famous snakes famous snake so yeah
right so you know at the Necronomicon is
oh yeah look at the zone necro yeah the
book of the dead so like God has the
book of the life there's also a
counterfeit version of that the
Necronomicon the everybody's names I
wanted to show that because they're
talking about all these
books that they're inspired by and they
threw it right in the kids movie I mean
the kids show you don't put Necronomicon
at kids show
so about the tricks or god this little
king of demons the cuddly demon guy they
called him a trickster god and the
wikipedia says in myth up mythology and
in the study of folklore and religion a
trickster as a character in a story God
got us spirit human or antrum up or some
long word which exhibits a great degree
of intellect or secret knowledge and
uses it to play tricks or otherwise
disobey normal rules and conventional
behavior the trickster crosses and often
breaks both physical and societal rules
tricksters violate principles of social
and natural order playfully disrupting
normal life and then re-establishing it
on a new basis often the bending
breaking of rules takes the form of
tricks or thievery tricksters can be
cunning or foolish or both the trickster
openly questions and mocks Authority
they are usually male characters and are
fond of breaking rules boasting and
playing tricks on both humans and gods
is that so do you remember what Joseph
Campbell attributed Yahweh s yeah there
wasn't a trickster god there's your
description yeah I'm just him but yeah
that's a description of Satan right
exactly he goes against authorities a
thief even mocks and blades tricks on
humans and gods so here he is king it
was once the powerful master of all
demons until he was trapped in a small
cute fluffy body now he seeks to restore
his title and glory so something
happened which we'll see in a clip that
caused him to be like he was this big
powerful king of demons and now he's
this little cute guy so you know if he's
the trickster God he's Satan and she
loves him if you look at this king of
demons character he looks like a dog
with a skull head this is exactly what
mythology is called a hell
and so he's from hell he's a hellhound
lose the the main character her name the
definition means brings light which is
similar to Lucifer the Light Bearer and
EDA also known as the owl lady of power
this is what I think Disney wiki said a
powerful rebellious witch who lose
befriends and takes her on as her
apprentice due to her rebellious nature
she is pretty much an outcast and the
criminal so this is the one that loses
looking up to she's her apprentice
lovely yeah
great role model so getting Disney on
board with this unique vision wasn't as
difficult as he or Tarrant or Terris
predicted but there was still pushback I
just do what I want and I let Disney
tell me if I'm going too far terrorists
described I'm always trying to push them
to go a bit darker and weirder because I
find that stuff fun there is sometimes a
concern with family networks for what is
considered family-friendly because
Disney is such a big company that in
certain corners they say they maybe they
don't want to take those risks hurch
said Walt Disney took those risks and
that's why we are sitting in this
building you have to remind yourself
that Disney is the full spectrum of
emotions creatures and scary things
that's interesting that she's
recognizing fascinating that Disney took
a risk in like what introducing
witchcraft to the population creatures
that we see yeah I mean you can
basically look at every Disney movie
that's in there so here is some what do
you call them concept sketches from the
this is not fan art this is by Dana
Terrace and what do we see in this
picture here ghosts like the White House
it's politics that
so if this is the type of stuff that
she's drawing and and she wants to keep
pushing for darker and creepier things
and she's just letting Disney like put
the reins on I mean it's not gonna be
long before this actually ends up in
there and right here she's got a big
book with a giant pentagram on there mmm
not hiding that either we we talked
about this in a previous show you know
there is such a real thing such as
ratings creep and so unless the the
public or people who are Christians are
always pushing against that you're
always gonna see values drift right
farther and farther and farther and in
you know one I guess what's perhaps
maybe as terrifying as a show is the
fact that Disney decided they don't have
a problem with it yeah you know and
they're gonna show about the girl
hanging out with a witch and hey let's
look at that one yeah so here's here's a
clip from the first episode I took
little snippet so we're going to go
through and just look at what the first
episode is pushing you know the pilot
basically is the template for the show
so me huh I love your creativity but
it's gotten out of hand
we all love that you express yourself
but if you can learn to separate fantasy
from reality you may need to spend the
summer here
[Music]
so the moms like we love your creativity
and all this but I want to send you to
this camp called think inside the box
yeah like you know these these shows are
always acting like you know in order to
fit in with the mold or whatever it's
just it's boring it's dull it's you're
thinking inside the box you can't be
creative you know that's what they're
trying to push here you got to do it you
know they're they're downing the idea no
don't don't do it your way when that's
really what they're upholding you know
through the character in the story arc
is do it your own way
yeah do what you want yeah goes though
well the main character she's real fun
and her parents are like no you need to
tame it down and I'm gonna send you to
this reform camp you know it's just like
the Paradise Hills send you to the
reform school so you'll want to marry
the prince and white so here's where she
she ends up slipping into the portal and
she ends up in this place
[Music]
did I die
am i in the bad place you wish
interesting scary yeah I mean the fact
that she even mentioned it yeah on a
kids show like did I die am I in the bad
place so how does she open the portal
you know when when her mom's walking her
out to like the bus or whatever waiting
for to go to this camp the mom the mom
leaves mom like throws her witchcraft
book basically it's a book about witches
in the trash when the mom walks off to
go to work the the daughter runs to find
her book in the trash and an owl has
taken it he's hopping along and she's
like oh come back here my book and goes
into this house and it just like she
ends up something to report
even the lesson there you know like oh
you know my parents tried to do
something but I just want to do it
anyway so I'm gonna do that instead you
know so even if they're trying to
protect you and throw something away
that's not good for you no no keep going
after it
yeah I need the owl lady the most
powerful witch on the boiling Isles of
which I am a respected Boston
Peter the owl lady you are wanted for
misuse of magic and demonic misdemeanors
you guys heard the language right she's
the most powerful witch and boiling
Isles was powerful witch in hell
and then this guy he he works for war he
works for warden wrath hmm so we'll talk
about humming a little bit but they're
after her because she's doing witchcraft
and she is doing demonic things and
they're they're open about it oh so
that's not okay in this world uh well
this world is controlled by the warden
who is the main antagonist which you'll
keep seeing that interesting
witchcraft is very real and very
dangerous and we have a free book for
you if you would like this book called
witchcraft ruins lives it's full of
amazing testimonies full of great
information and Bible verses this book
is yours free no shipping and handling
if you're in the United States just
click the link below it's a little like
Studios TV towards slash free - offer
this book is yours
back to the show this is the boiling
Isles every myth you humans have is
caused by a little of our world leaking
into yours yep Griffins vampires drafts
giraffes so like she's talking about you
know a little bit of your world slipping
into it's like hell and Earth or
slipping back and forth and that's why
you have like vampires and even giraffes
or some kind of like demonic entities or
even putting them on the same playing
field like you know as normal as a
giraffe yeah so I'm showing these clips
just to show like how blatantly open
they are like what this place is
welcome to the owl house
[Applause]
this place is beautiful do you live here
all alone
little guy how she snapped her fingers
and brooms are like sweeping themselves
and candles are lighting and she's like
this is the most beautiful place like
imagine being in that situation of real
life
you follow a witch into her house she
snaps her fingers and a broom starts
moving on its own and candles are
lighting on their own and she's like oh
so beautiful and then she's hugging the
king of demons this this is so like
alarming in in a Christian sense like I
really really hope that a none of our
viewership is watching this even though
a lot of the questions that came in I
mean we do take those questions
seriously a lot of questions came in on
this particular show what about the owl
house what about the owl House and so
that's one of the reasons why we're
wanting to address this but for a
Christian I mean this is such a serious
matter we brought these verses up before
but I want to read to you a couple of
verses Leviticus 1931 says regard not
them that have familiar spirits spirits
neither seek after the Wizards be to be
defiled by them for I am the Lord your
God and Leviticus 20 verse 6 says and
the soul that turns after these familiar
spirits and after these wizards and goes
whoring after them I will set my face
against that soul and I will cut him off
from my people my that's some harsh
words and once again that's God's
speaking that's read letter
Old Testament that's literally the words
coming from God saying listen this is
how serious this matter is I will turn
my face against those people that do
these kind of things so what does that
mean for us I mean you know just
passively observe
these are watching them and you know
liking them I think that that liking or
participating in this is engaging in it
in the same way that you would if you
were actually out there practicing it
yeah yeah and you know you might watch
it and just think well I'd never be into
this but it's humorous or whatever but
children are getting intrigued by this
and they're like there's something this
is real I can do this for real
tell me more you know that was my
experience like that lady the movie the
craft I saw it and they they made it
look so real that I began to search
forums and stuff and look up what people
are practicing wicked and their
experiences and that just makes you want
more and more it's all about that power
and seeing that it is real you know I
think Bible as a principal in it about
people who are ministers and and and one
of the responsibilities of a minister
says in Ezekiel 44 23 and they shall
teach my people the difference between
the holy and the unholy and caused them
to discern between the unclean and the
clean part of the reason people I think
are asking these type of questions so
like what about this and what about that
is because they're not reading the Bible
and the people who are are there that
are teaching them I guess for lack of a
better word are not teaching them how to
discern between right and wrong good and
evil and so people who are ministers
need to be very careful and and teach
people the truth of God's Word you know
because this this should be a no-brainer
that should be I mean instantaneously
just like no I'm not gonna watch that
wouldn't put my kid before it you know
don't have anything to do with it and
the reason I want to address is just to
kind of warn the parent who might be
like oh how house yeah go ahead and
watch it and they're not you know
investigating but I mean like I said
just the article with news
she's open about all this it's not our
opinion it's not you know some theories
it's just blatant and bold and openly
admitted let me explain
King was once a mighty king of demons
until his crown of power was stolen and
he became this you mean this little
bundle of joy the crown is being held by
the evil warden Rath and locked away
behind a magical force field that only a
human can break through a human like you
so the story the plot of the story what
do you see biblically or I mean it's
interesting that it's being held by
someone of wrath warden wrath warden of
wrath when it talks about you know God
he's the one that will administer his
wrath and no nobody can can it get to
him but a human there is a human god
that was the mediator you know yeah so
he was like the king of the world or
whatever and and his position was taken
by this warden wrath and now he has lost
his power but the human is gonna help
him get his power back Wow
so this is they're they're trying to get
his crown his crown is actually in this
prison that the warden rules over and so
this is the scene
the confirmatory 'm a place for those
considered unsuitable for society wow
these guys really have the hots for you
yep but we are never caught because
we're too silvery hey cat lady how'd you
get out of yourself oh no no no I'm not
a cat also I'm not a criminal not yet
you're not
neither are we stupid warden like to
lock people up who don't fit in wait
these aren't crimes none of you actually
did anything wrong you're all just a
bunch of weirdos like me is it fair that
they're all in here they just want to be
themselves why does everyone think that
being a weirdo is so bad cause weirdos
have to stick together you know well we
owe you one
now that's gonna out of here before the
warden finds us and loses his head too
late and that's why it's a kids show cuz
there wasn't like the blood splattering
out and all that it's a joke yeah crazy
yeah review what just happened
it's interesting that the first part of
the clip she's like oh that's why we
never get caught because we're slippery
dealing with the devil is a slippery
slope it's like you don't it's like you
can't identify it or identify him or
what he's doing on till you way down the
path you like Wow how did I get here and
it started from something small and it's
like a slippery slope so that's what
came to mind when she said that it was
interesting and of how it was so easy
for this child to identify with all
these people it took like five seconds
like oh they're different I'm different
too how about we all come together as
she looks at the picture of the witch
and the demon king right different just
like me yeah and you know what's so
wrong with being weird it's just that's
who we are you know why are we being put
in prison for being who we were born I
was born this way alright the warden is
throwing you in jail because you're not
conforming in the places but the
confirmatory yeah picked up on that oh
man it's just you know this is the same
thing we see over and over especially
with Disney and you know it's not just
blatantly pushing witchcraft and demon
summoning but also the fact that you
know to go against the law of this world
the ruler I keep trying to like you know
okay
take a look at it and see if I can see
it from their perspective okay so like
let's just say that this evil Lord that
is part of this conformity reom is the
devil okay let's just say this for
argument's sake right the devil doesn't
want to force you into one way of living
his whole MO is do what you want be who
you want to be it's not any sort of
rules that you really need to live by
and so you you you kind of can't view it
from that side of the thing you can only
view it if there is somebody that is
quote-unquote controlling everybody and
wanting them to be a certain thing and
conform them to be that can only be a
description of God you can't see that in
another way and any other you know any
other option would be maybe the
government and so either way it's
teaching you to rebel against laws fight
against the oppressor
we will conquer we will never be afraid
of you you will creep
let this be a lesson to all of you
there's no place in society for you if
you can't fit in interesting yeah so
it's like he's gonna ultimately destroy
people that don't fit so in this moment
they're attacking the warden the warden
Rath and this whole breaks open oh they
slap all the switches and open up the
cells and then she asks this question
why are you guys just standing there
this is your chance to escape the warden
attaches he always does we belong here
self-doubt is a prison you could never
escape from so you have a different way
of doing things a different way of
seeing things that may make you weird
but it also makes you awesome don't you
see why are you helping us because us
weirdos have to stick together
[Applause]
so just looking at that from a Ray
Christian perspective there has to be a
punishment for those that don't follow
God's commandments this is very
reminiscent of Satan rallying the troops
I need to take the heavenly City right
you know opening all the go against the
warden you know and it even made me
think of Revelation 20 it describes the
angel coming down having a chain to the
bottomless pit you know in the sense of
their being held like in a prison if you
will by the warden warden wrath so you
break down the words warden is an
enforcement of specified laws and wrath
is punishment for an offense or a crime
or divine chastisement Wow it's
literally the enforcer the enforcer of
laws which is God and he punishes those
who disobey so is this character wearing
a mask I can't quite tell ya it's uh
this is a mass play it says
old-fashioned plague mass like the
doctors would say you never really see
his face oh he takes it off and it was
just like a huge giant mouth with teeth
it was fire out and stuff yeah the whole
thing about no one should be punished
for being who they are you know that's
what we constantly hear right you hear
that from all different types of people
I was born this way why would it you
know why would God punish me for being
Who I am
well you know I might just feel like an
alcoholic I might just feel it why the
guy got punched me because I want to get
drunk all the time you know yeah it's
such a weird because you have you know
we're born in a world of sin and and
because of sin we we have these
inherited or developed you know traits
and then we look at God and we and and
we almost come to God like man why did
you do this to me yeah you know but but
at the same time God is over here saying
but you don't have to be that way I can
change you
but how many of us take got up on that
you know and there's a lot of people out
there that are like but I don't want to
change yeah you know yeah because like
but I can change it but I don't want to
change he's like but if you don't change
there's only there's only one path for
that you know and and I'm offering to
you I can change you
I mean what more can God do he made a
way when when there was no yeah it's
like we're given a choice and then we're
mad at the consequences of the choice
that we made yeah that's what it boils
down to do not underestimate me warden
wrath for I am loose the human piece
she's like I mean just that whole
statement right there she's like you
know coming against warden wrath I am
loose the humans suffer right and I'm
you know I'm here for peace which the
Bible talks about when they say peace
and safety sudden destruction I come
upon them hmm
I clearly this is a real peace because
she throws a firecracker in his mouth
and explains the behavior of atheists or
non-religious people is pretty
consistent whenever you approach them
with any religious topic they're so
against it it's like they're protective
of their beliefs so like no like I don't
even want to hear it stop talking and
this might sound a little messed up but
I think that more Christians should
adopt that in opposition to some of
these things once once you see the
warning signs you're like nope I don't
even want to hear it I don't want to see
it you know I'm going to protect myself
and especially on my children you know I
think so imagine if an atheist had a kid
and you start talking to my Jesus
protect at all cost exactly I remember
our episode about holy Olga when Eric
Wilson was here with us and he was just
making mention how Christians are so
adopting of other religions but he you
wouldn't see a Buddhist baptizing their
children you know I doubt I would find a
sane worshiper flipping through the
channels and letting their kids watch
TBN or 3abn or some kind of Christian
show but we're flipping through the
channel and on Disney and let our kids
view this you know we need to be just as
protective just as prayerful about what
we choose to not only for us to watch
but our children our future proverbs
says train up a child in the way you
should go you know it's an active thing
I think it's you know it's the lack of
options that make us feel hopeless or
like but there's nothing else to what
you know there's not good options well
it is the narrow way only if you were
gonna find it you know the Broadway
elite you know Broadway think about me
it's the broad way that leads to
destruction you know yeah we need more
discernment and we hope by doing these
kind of shows you know you're seeing a
pattern over and over and over again
similar things popping up similar verses
being used and you're starting to see
it's not just one film it's not just
nitpicking this one movie or whatever
it's this pattern that that keeps
progressively coming down the pipe and
to me what's even more alarming is the
children I mean that that's why we did
we when we made the Magic Kingdom the
whole documentary on little kids I mean
that was simply talking about mainstream
Disney films that everybody has seemed I
mean like the most common Disney things
that are out there and and showing this
pattern within there it's like man
they've been doing this literally for a
long time yes it's becoming more
blatantly upfront but these kind of
concepts witchcraft you know using the
elements all of those things like we
discussed in that documentary are
literally you know it's it's just like
here's the fruit of that no down the
road
so she actually helped them get the
crown back for him or whatever and she
was going to be allowed to go back home
and this is where they're telling her
goodbye and just see what happens
oh and don't forget this
[Music]
okay I know you got your head cut off
and we started some kind of prison riot
but this was the most fun I've ever had
I don't see it at home you don't fit in
here if I stay we could not fit in
together I am NOT going back to summer
camp what summer camp what are we
talking about here I want to stay and
become a witch like you and Ozora what
if you teach me to become a witch I'll
do anything you want all right
I'll teach you how to be a witch but you
have to work for me before you learn any
spells deal
[Music]
and there is our house what did you
think about that last scene right there
yeah I mean the fact that she's just
like yeah I want to become a witch I
want to become a witch
and she's like I think I'm gonna like it
here you know I don't want to go back
home I don't fit in there I fit in here
in hell right right
and I think it goes all the way back to
the scene of when when we get to heaven
the only people that are there in heaven
of the people that want to be there
mm-hmm I mean like God's not gonna force
you to be therein and unfortunately this
is like making people choose sides it's
like you are now sympathizing with yeah
you know what I am kind of weird and I
don't want to be perfect and I don't
want to be you know righteous and I have
flaws and I need to celebrate those
flaws I mean this is like literally an
mo of our society of where we are today
and it does not shock me that something
like this would be coming out but you
know once again to see the kids really
being indoctrinated with this concept
it's just like oh my goodness you know
can you imagine where we're gonna go in
one more generation Oh scary yeah I mean
I bet Disney would say that they don't
promote religion in their shows Wicca is
a religion you're pushing your religious
beliefs interesting on children you know
I think they just need to start being
honest and say you know what every
religion is okay we just don't like
Christianity I mean they just need to be
honest like that you know put that on
the front of you and your paper Buddhism
or whatever right yeah you ever seen a
Christian movie from Disney yeah I've
seen even Buddhist I think probably you
know we should do we should write a
script and send it in their response
yeah I mean it's all full of
righteousness and like a little kid just
like never thinks of himself he's just
like self-sacrificing they're like I
don't know about this what if he cut his
head off
yeah I know what if he goes against the
rules because he's really weird
yeah for Christians I would ask when you
when you read the Bible you know or are
you taking it seriously are you trying
to really apply it to your life when you
read Psalms 101 and it says I will set
no wicked thing before my eyes are you
taking that seriously because God is
serious
the devil is serious you know are you
which side will you fall on yeah the
other thing I would say in this this
might sound kind of disparaging at first
but people have this this mindset of
what am I going to watch yeah as if
entertainment is the pinnacle of life
and that that's what you should be
consumed with it's not God has so much
more to fill your life with than just
the next show or the next movie or the
next you know Broadway musical or the
next song that comes out on the radio or
whatever all those things largely are
distractions that's right filling your
mind with you know the wrong kind of
theology we should be asking God God
what do you want to do with my life and
you'll be surprised when you when you
approach God with what do you want me to
do with my life and my children your
time will fill up and he will have
things for you to do and then you'll
look back and wonder how did I have so
much time before to watch all these
things people ask me to watch stuff now
and I'm just like even if it's a
ministry video I'm like I don't know if
I could work about it in you know I got
a lot to do so God is good and God will
God will fill up your life with godly
things and it's it's getting to the
point where it's too much of a risk to
just you know yeah go sit down and watch
whatever you can't do that there are too
many evil things out there that some of
them appear good at first and some of
them don't even appear good at first you
know but I would be very cautious if I
was a parent you know I am cautious as a
parent but I would be cautious if you're
a parent out there and you think about
this one concept as well for all of you
guys that are watching you know when you
give money to Disney Plus
what's that subscription that's yeah I
don't know ninety-nine a month unless
you got in on that is it is it really I
don't know yeah you are supporting this
type of work that when you're supporting
literally right wow this is a ministry I
mean when you place it in those kind of
realms this is a ministry so you know
just just a simple subtle way that you
can say you know what I don't I don't
stand for this and I'm not gonna support
this kind of work try a media fast you
know if your kids are really involved in
media and they're watching stuff all the
time begging you to watch stuff all the
time take a moment and just say sit your
family down during family worship or
something and just say hey you know what
this next week we're gonna go through a
media fast and in we're gonna take that
time and we're gonna like you know
either read the Bible together play
games together do something for someone
else go rake your neighbors leaves go do
something that would be quote unquote in
line with Christianity and just just
notice how the mood will change
something you know regarding parish
field I think it's important for parents
to give their kids the right
entertainment and and also keep their
mind occupied with gardening because
those kids are the people the generation
that's gonna grow up to be later
influenced gonna that's right if they
are being influenced by this in the
future they will make our world like
that so that's right okay good food
amenities on a downward spiral with each
generation because they just keep
pushing it like she said a little darker
well that generation is gonna think this
isn't we're in dark let's go a little
bit weirder darker mm-hm excellent point
in the show we hope you guys enjoy that
show we hope you see that this is very
clearly not something for Christians and
I hope nobody's kids are watching this
stuff you can just see from straight
from the horse's mouth that this is
demonic and it's witchcraft they don't
they don't even try to call it something
else magic you know it's witchcraft so
if you guys liked the show click
subscribe click the little bill so
you'll be notified and we look forward
to seeing you guys every Friday at noon
join us for the premiere so you can get
in that chat and contact with us right
then and if not you leave a comment at
the bottom and one of us will check it
and we want to hear your opinions we
want to hear what you guys want to see
so we know what to cover we'll see you
guys next Friday
god bless don't forget to share
[Music]